les premiers rayons de soleil de l'année
rime souvent avec les premières sorties
en terrasse mais comme chaque samedi
les dijonnais devront composer avec un
invité qui devient un habitué
on a un petit peu oublier les manifs et
on s'est dit qu'on allait s'installer au
soleil et puis lens fait un peu
surprendre et on n'avait pas trop prévu
ça on va avoir un petit coup vite fait
sa rentrée à la maison
les commerçantes du centre-ville eux ont
mis en place leur petite routine après
14 semaines de mobilisation
la machine est bien rodée en général par
contre ils sont plutôt fidèles dont qui
passe à 15h et à 17h donc en fait qu'à
aux alentours de 15 heures à 17 heures
il va falloir laisser les grilles autant
au mois de décembre n'était pas
forcément très rôdée la clientèle était
très frileuse et ne venaient pas
forcément on pense qu'il dirait
peut-être leur achat d'un samedi à
l'autre et puis maintenant que les
habitudes sont prises les clients
viennent avant et après ils vont prendre
un café pendant depuis trois mois dès
samedi jaune
les promeneurs ont pris l'habitude de
s'organiser pour éviter les cortèges ou
pour composer avec dans la mesure où
manifestent pas on n'a pas envie de
d'avoir des vapeurs de gaz lacrymogènes
ou des foules qui viennent comme ça ce
n'est pas très agréable donc donc on
évite l c'est super compliqué parce que
j'habite au centre-ville et du tout de
suite eu le temps de lever
on n'est pas besoin de sortir en fait
mais pour ce gilet jaune
la perturbation est ponctuel et les
dérangements moindre certains souffrent
vraiment et viennent manifester
et voilà on pressent tous les gens
d'acheter regarder la rue de la liberté
la manifestation est passée à dijon mais
on voit très bien qu'il ya encore de
l'activité avait effectivement pendant
15 20 minutes une petite perturbation
mais après la vie reprend son cours
une perturbation donc temporaires en
début d'après midi qui n'a pas empêché
les badauds de profiter du beau temps et
du retour du printemps avant les
tensions de la fin de journée